um but i think we can all see and even i
have learned a lot i didn't fully know
this until i started explaining it
it's a battle over the target position
over the posh over posturing of the
kings which is what makes it so
complicated there's all these intricate
maneuvers as both sides
uh try to insist on and fulfill their
own goal
table base makes us all look very very
easy this is
quite brilliant actually
so caruana mbl a game which by now is
pretty famous
i'll begin this by saying for my youtube
audience you know that this analysis is
going to have significantly more
uh mistakes than you know some other
recaps because i'm not gonna use the
engine
and the reason i don't use the engine is
because well there's a couple i won't go
into it too much
but well first of all it's not as fun
for me selfishly second of all
you can use the engine yourself and look
over the game and you can learn a lot
about it there's nothing wrong with that
but i think my j i view my job as
somebody who can be a conduit between
you
you know the viewer and the minds of the
gm's and when you use the engine
uh to figure everything out the lines
between
what the players are thinking and what
the engines are saying begins to be
blurred so you don't have a good sense
of like
what actually was going on so i'm gonna
make a lot of mistakes and stuff
and those of you in the chat who who
have looked at the game with an engine
you guys can correct me and stuff i
don't mind that i might turn the engine
on in a couple of moments
uh but i won't have it on throughout the
whole game so this is a poison pond
nighter
as you guys know and uh night or bishop
g5 e6
mvl uh back to what he's been playing
for his essentially his whole life which
is
the poison pawn variation against queen
b against bishop g5
and uh fabby plays queen v2 the poison
pawn
has a pretty interesting history uh it
was first played in the year
1899 which is quite incredible and then
it was played the second time in 1954.
it was played a lot by russian players
so it's it's been around for over 50
years
um it's been around for over 50 years
and
the theory has grown and grown and grown
and then when computers appeared it grew
exponentially
so fischer played it uh people knew
about this in the pre-computer time
but nobody really suspected how
incredibly complicated it was
until you know 10 15 years ago and it
got really really popular again
so the in the old days in the old days
uh you know people used to play the move
f5 here
and even bishop b2 nowadays e5 is the
very topical move
so e5 is still very much theory
h6 that's also the theoretical response
counter attacking the bishop
the bishop drops to h4 taking the knight
here doesn't make any sense because
takes the knight takes the pawn
this bish this dark skirt bishop is an
incredibly valuable attacker for white
you know you can say oh but wait a
second i win the pawn back
but you've helped black develop his
pieces
and after knight c6 white's in big
trouble because this bishop is x-raying
the knights white is no attack the whole
point
of the poison pawn is well to sacrifice
a pawn for an attack
so bishop h4 d-e-f-e and this often
occurs
via the move order take stakes h6 bishop
h4 that's also possible
uh it's just a transposition takes takes
knight fd7 this is still incredibly
common theory
94 by fabi centralizing his knight in
sacrificing essentially two more pawns
so uh it's quite rare for a gambit in
theory to sacrifice three pawns
that's exactly what this is um mvl takes
on a2
this is still over almost 2 000 games in
this position rook has to move
and mbl goes uh queen d5 the main line
and you guys are welcome to ask
questions by the way so knight takes e5
here
uh it has never been played and for very
very good reason
as you guys can see the queen x-rays the
d8 square
and white will have to choose very
carefully where to put the knight
but among other things knight f5 looks
incredibly strong
because queen d8 mate is a threat and
knight d6 is the threat black is busted
so it's time for mbl to evacuate the
queen queen d5
still very much still theory i know
that's a meme but but it is theory
and phabby shifts his queen to e3
mainline opening up the rook's
x-ray on the queen and protecting both
of his knights
and how can we take c5 so don't be under
any illusions here
still about 1800 games in this position
but this is where crazy stuff begins to
happen because
almost everybody exclusively has gone
bishop e2
and bishop e2 is essentially considered
force just for your information and my
reference it's showing
1726 games with bishop b2 and the move
that fabby played c3
has 12 games and not a single one of
those 12
by anybody particularly strong there's a
couple correspondence games
it's insane uh that he found a move this
early
now the reason bishop e2 is the main
line is quite simple i mean you're just
developing your bishop
it's a crazy position super complicated
another reason is that you're stopping
the move at 5
which seems to win the knight and now
bishop h5 just literally leads to
checkmate
so that's the other idea of bishop p2
and now the main line continues
bishop c5 then bishop g3
and now recently uh nbl has started to
play queen to d5
we're not going to delve into this
position this is incredibly computerised
theory
uh and all a lot of these games often
end in draws
i don't think he found it at the board
trust me fabi knows
has known this theory since he was
probably five years old this is
incredibly common everybody knows this
c3 nobody has ever seen before
um i don't know if the engine gives the
move c3
as its top choice i can check um
if we turn on stockfish yeah so you can
see bishop b2
uh is is the main move now this is a
pretty low depth it's my computer's
running very slowly because
i'm also streaming
yeah it's particularly slow let me see
it shouldn't
be this low but okay you can see bishop
b2 is the move
and if we expand the list of moves c3 is
number two
c3 is is mentioned it's number two but
it says black is better
it says black is better after bishop b7
which mbl did not play
and look and this is what people really
struggle with a lot of
a lot of you might say well why would
carolina prepare this if white is worse
but
minus point three might not be telling
the whole story remember this is a super
irrational position
black has three pawns up uh
so minus point three doesn't tell you
anything about the position and how hard
it is to play
from a human perspective i'm seeing that
people ran this on depth 42 it's only
point two so white takes y goes knight
f3
and i think fabi's point uh
and what his team discovered is that
this is just a very hard position to
play
for black so let's say bishop e2 for
example
and the computer gives like an only move
you know only moves that that lead to a
slight edge for black but maybe that
final position 10 moves in is actually
equal you don't know
so that's the bottom line and this moves
c3 it's not a novelty it's been played
before
but it also should be mentioned that
against the main move bishop e2 and the
the main continuation is bishop c5 so
figuring out that you have to go bishop
e7 here
and get your king out into the center
like this would have been incredibly
hard for mbl
and all of these decisions that go into
these moves it's not just
fabi turning on his engine and letting
it sit for a day
it's also these human decisions will mbl
find bishop e7
that's why you hire a whole team of
people to make all those decisions and
to analyze the hell out of this
i mean he literally had a year so does
that make sense so far
like what is the actual point behind c3
we're well about we're about to find out
because nvl played bishop c5 as you
usually do after bishop e2
and the point here first fabi drops his
bishop to g3
this is still not a novelty six games
and after queen d5 comes the absolutely
shocking
novelty this probably will be the
novelty of the year
now you guys might notice the x-ray
of the rook against the queen the
problem is that you can't move the
knight because the bishop is going to
capture a white's queen
and in this position everybody who
reached this position went bishop to d6
sacking the bishop
and then knight b5 opening up the attack
on the queen
but this is not as good as it looks
because black can just sack the queen
and
black is a rook of peace and three pawns
for the queen and white's initiative
fizzles out here
but fabi plays bishop c4 sacking the
other bishop
insane getting the bishop out
sacrificing it
just to get the queen onto a vulnerable
onto a vulnerable square
and only now does he play the move
bishop to d6
which of course stops black from
castling and now
the vulnerability of the screen is
revealed because you can't take the
bishop you get forked
and black is up a piece and three pawns
and
despite all that he has an incredibly
hard time
moving a single piece because of white's
incredible pressure here
so that's just insane
now for example if nbl tries to bring
his knight out let's say knight c6 right
what did fabi have in mind here well i
think bishop takes c5 is totally
devastating
because after knight takes c5 the d6
square has been cleared and
this is a fork against black's king so
insanely it's tremendously hard to make
a move
white is threatening bishop takes c5
now you might look at this and say well
what about taking the knight here with
the bishop
okay but now the rook takes the bishop
the queen has to move
and look at this position just with your
own eyes black cannot move a muscle
why just castles white gets pressure
down the f-file this looks completely
lost for black even though he's up a
zillion pieces
there's just nothing to talk about or
analyze here
and uh if queen takes c5 by the way well
queen takes e5 is impossible you just
take the queen and nbl was sitting there
just in disbelief and he found what i
think is a good idea
he found a way to give away his bishop
such that he gets a little bit of
breathing room for his pieces okay
um now can't black sack is queen after
rook d4 well this is a different
situation
than this situation here black's pieces
are fine
whites are all over the place in this
position black is completely paralyzed
thank you jaren gifting the subs
right and white's threatening queen g7
it's not just about the material
advantage it's also about the fact that
black can't move anything
mvl finds the best move knight to f6
okay so
he's getting his knight to a civilized
square he's making room for the other
knight potentially
and he's immediately challenging the
knight on e4 so if you play bishop c5
well that would be very bad
because mbl would take on e4 and uh
so sky sky bob was just those of you
just joining
uh all of this was theory up until
fabi's 16th move c3 incredibly common
theory
mbl should have taken all those pawns
the poison pawn
variation is a bit of a misnomer it the
pawn is not actually truly poisoned
so i think some people will be under the
illusion that mbl went into some line
that's always been considered bad
poison pond is one of the most topical
lines of the night off
and we all spent 30 minutes thank you
for letting me know so does everybody
say bishop c594 is bad because you
dropped the bishop and you have no
knight to give a fork with
so fabby has to play knight takes c5
and mvl centralizes his knight on d5
now he's up three pawns fabby has won
the piece back
and white's queen is under attack fabi
has to move it
and fabi moves it to e5 essentially
sacrificing
a fourth pawn emblem didn't take it
and the reason emil didn't take it is
because it would have
i think it would have helped white white
would have played king f2 coordinating
the rooks
it seems to me that this standoff
between the queens is probably in
white's favor
given how active white's pieces are in
addition the c file being open
doesn't seem significant right but if
blackbeard's rook g8
i think rook c1 might be a very nasty
move here creating
tremendous pressure against black's
bishop so at this point
mbl's point is just to try to get his
pieces out he doesn't care about any
more pawns
he's up three pawns that's enough now
this pawn on g7
is hanging and if white takes it the
rook is going to be trapped
so mvl goes rook to g8
there were other ways to defend the pawn
but they were bad
who can find that white's response had
nbl played f6
okay when h5 check is correct guys
f6 creates a devastating weakness and uh
this is well the king can't go to d7 has
to go to d8 and this is totally crushing
this is totally totally crushing the
queen swoops in d5 is hanging
it's over um
any questions in this position uh i just
want to make sure everybody's on board
with
why things are looking very dangerous
for black and why nbl has to make this
ugly looking move rook g8
so as many of you are asking why didn't
fabi now take the knight
well when you make a move like bishop
takes b you got to look at how the
position changes which pieces are no
longer defended
and what immediately jumps out at me is
that the knight on c5 has lost
its defender queen takes c5 happens and
all things held equal
trades are horrible for white whites
down a lot of pawns
so white's initiative fizzles out here
we have a question about why knight f6
can't be played but here's the funny
thing after knight f6
this knight on c5 is now defended by the
queen so now i think fabi could have
considered taking
but in addition mbl's knight just came
from f6 the knight being on d5
renders the d file closed so i think
a move like knight f5 would have been
quite devastating as well
so mbl has to go here now fabby
sacrifices another piece he plays
knight d takes e6 ripping through the e
file
but this one i think is quite
understandable you know
you've as the russian expression goes
having said a you have to say
b he's already sacked three pawns why
not you gotta open up black's king
and he does this to open up the e file
the queen is now facing the king mbl
grabs it
and fabby plays knight takes c6
so the first thing to know to
uh mention is that if bishop takes c6
white vacuums up
black's hanging pieces queen e6 and now
the simplest i think
is just to take the rook and then to
take the knight and white is up a rook
and i'm sure there's there's other winds
here there's maybe even a mate
you could probably take the knight first
that's not possible
the other way to deal with the threat of
a discovered check
is to move the king but there's nowhere
good to move it in the event of king f7
uh in addition to just taking the knight
one line that jumps out at me
no that's probably not good so i think
taking the knight would be
sufficient but i was thinking about rook
f1 check
but the funny thing is black can even
sack the queen but even knight f6 seems
to defend against the immediate threats
you can't castle through it through a
check castling is illegal because the
queen defends f1
but i think after rook d5 bishop e6 now
rook f1 looks good
king g6 black is running away
which is kind of funny queen takes e6
the king
runs away to h7 here black looks
relatively safe although
probably after something like bishop e5
white is still winning
yeah i wonder what the exact mating line
here is although i'm sure white has
something
it just it just smells smells like
checkmate
um i call that safe well it's safer than
it was here
so i guess we'll have to look at that
but um at what point i don't know when
fabio was out of his prep maybe somebody
could tell me
somebody who saw the press conference i
don't know when fabio was out of his
prep that's the scary part
well queen f5 they're still net f6 let's
check the engine here
i'm gonna take one of my freebies and
take a look at
the engine here we're only going to do
that a couple of times as i said
and amazingly at least according to the
initial
evaluation let's see well knight d8 rook
takes knight d8 i'm not sure what that
does just blunders tonight
let's see it takes a second to load
so it's showing a draw it believe it or
not king f7 is showing
a draw at a pretty high depth now
and that's pretty insane because what
this tells you and this is why i don't
use an engine guys
my every one of my corner called
grandmaster instincts
says that king f7 should get mated if
you're looking at this with an engine
initially
you see the move king f7 how could mbl
not play this is such an obvious move
well it's not an obvious move you go
right into this check
after knight f6 it turns out according
to the engine that white has nothing
better
than to sacrifice this knight and give
this very interesting perpetual
and if black tries to block with g6 then
white sacks the rook
and swings the queen to e7 with mate
and uh rook takes d5 bishop takes c6 the
line i gave
is equal it's dynamically equal and
white actually has to
has to be the one to play accurately
rook f8 is forced
that's a pretty hard move to see and
i guess this leads to a perpetual after
queen takes e3
because black's king is in tremendous
danger
so black has to check white's king ad
nauseum
so it is safe and it appears
that queen takes c3 mbl's move was still
fine also leads to equality
but this end game which arose
seems to me to be very hard to play for
black so king f7 was a chance for mbl
to draw the game essentially by force
but instead maxime goes queen c3 check
which forces a queen trade
and we get into an amazing scenario
where the queens have been traded
mbl is a piece up and two pawns up
and yet he's not winning or anything of
the sword in fact he's the one on his
back feet
and the reason is that fabi starts with
a check knight c7 that's a fork
okay ambeal drops his king to f7 but of
course if you take the rook
well then black takes white's rook and
the position fizzles out and black is up
two pawns
that's no good but fabi goes rook to d3
very important intermediate move there's
a couple things to understand here the
knight is saying the rook is hanging
black is still extremely underdeveloped
and
the king is very very weak just because
the queens have been traded doesn't mean
that the king
is all of a sudden safe fabby now in his
pocket has the ability to castle with
chuck that might be a good
good idea okay
so mbl decides that the best approach is
to prioritize the safety of his king
and he gives up the rook he goes 94.
remember that he's still up a piece and
have two pawns
even after giving up the rook he's going
to be technically speaking material is
going to be approximately equal
now some of you might be wondering why
didn't he go rook a7 i'm wondering the
same thing
and my guess is that the reasoning is
quite mundane
perhaps just rook takes c3
and if we can imagine that let's say
black develops his knight
why king castle will check but i even
think rook g3 comes to mind
what is the point of this move the point
of this move is to control g6 with the
rook
castles is literally a meat threat this
is a hilarious checkmate
okay you can play like this with this is
mate but apparently this is what black
was supposed to do
and perhaps the move knight d7 comes to
mind here
in order to meet castles with knight f6
kind of like what mbl did just
without giving up the rook and who can
tell me why
this move doesn't trap the rook you guys
might be looking the same way
wait a minute black stroke is trapped
black's work is lost why is that not the
case
what are we missing here
it's not a fork the knight is the knight
is a pin by the whites rook
no no no not 94 the knight is pinned the
move is b6
creating a square for the rook it's
funny how black has been giving away his
extra pieces until now he's got an extra
pawn now white is not worse here after
let's say bishop d4 clearly white's
piece activity will compensate for the
extra pawn but we have opposite colored
bishops
sorry we have opposite colored bishops
no that's not the good movement playbook
d8 it seems like black
has finally gotten his pieces into the
game and the position is going to fizzle
out into a draw
so apparently as people in the chat are
indicating rook a7 was the
last chance to maintain dynamic equality
so some of you and
you know youtube people as well might be
looking at this analysis and
and progressively saying i thought this
was a great novelty but i'm discovering
that it was all bluff well it wasn't all
bluff
chess has essentially been exhausted
these openings have been exhausted to
the point where nobody's going to refute
them anymore
all that you can find are ways to test
your opponent and make your opponent
find difficult moves
and doing that is no less meaningful
than refuting someone at this point
that's
that's what novelties are about in the
modern day
dynamic equality by the way when i use
that phrase it means
a position that's not literally balanced
in the sense that it's
rook and three versus rook and three the
position is unbalanced
but still equal so for example a
situation which you have full
compensation for a pawn but not more
is dynamic equality one side is upon but
the other side is full compensation
okay 94 was played by ambeal fabby
castles with check mbl goes king g6
so i suppose he didn't want to play
knight f6 he just centralizes his knight
and now after knight c6 fabby is up in
exchange for two pawns
thank you smoother planet but mbl has
finally gotten its pieces out and the
king is now safe
one of the functions that this knight
fulfills is covering the g3 square so
this is no longer possible
fabi's knight is now in trouble so he
has to drop it back
and naviol goes rook to d8 pinning the
bishop to the rook and forcing fabi's
hand the bishop
is in trouble if you try to go rook
after d1
defending the bishop and bishop g4 comes
out
that's no good for white because the
rook doesn't have this square
and fabi must therefore give up this
hero of a knight knight c
rook c8 the position finally begins to
fizzle out into an end game to something
that we can really follow and understand
but it's still tremendously complex
the big thing to understand is that
when you have a situation where one side
is up in exchange
the fact that it's an end game is good
for the side of the two rooks because
the knights
are not long range pieces and what the
knights have the most heart
the the hardest time doing is
multitasking
because the knight is a short range
piece think of it this way
either the knight supervises the queen
side pawns sorry
or thank you poor dome it nope i don't
want to play this move
either it supervises the queenside pawns
or it supervises the king and the
knights cannot apportion
uh these tasks particu pretty well
they're just overextended
they're not very good defensive pieces
and fabi utilizes that in the next
couple of moves
uh to get more favorable transformations
if that makes sense so
to that effect if let's finally make
this move let's say mbl pushes b5
well what is the drawback of this move
one way to consider it is that the
knight on c6 loses its protector
rook c1 happens and well the pawns are
not going to go very far
now is bishop takes before a good move
here
yes or no
no night takes before you might be
excited ah we won the rook
but black takes the other rook so you
gotta be careful but
no problem i can drop the bishop back
and black spawns are not going to get
very far anyway
because look at how the rooks are able
to hit both knights and very very
quickly you're going to get a situation
where the knights are driven off the
board
the pawns lose their protection and the
rook just mops them up pretty easily
so it might be confusing to some people
why envel didn't push his pawns well
that's why the pawns wouldn't
wouldn't go anywhere anyway mbl goes
rook c7 instead
uh he's actually protecting his pawns
daddy plays rook up four uh kicking the
knight away
after knight f6 the bishop has done his
job on a3 he repositions it to b2
putting more pressure on the knight
mvl tries to bring the other knight to
help the king's side
fabby trades in order to ruin
black kingside pawn structure in the
anticipation that he's going to win one
of these pawns
that's totally reasonable
and fabi pushes h4 so he grabs some
space on the king side
he prevents king g5 and
you know he's got the idea of going rook
d6
and perhaps going g4 so nbl stops the
progress that responds with h5
but in doing so the pawn on h5 now
becomes a weakness and fabi finds a very
very nice sequence
rook g3 check the king has to stick to
the f pawn it can't go to the h val you
can't lose this pawn
after king f7 using this pin
fabby goes rook g5 hitting the pawn
there's no good way to defend it
but mtl does find a way to get a pawn in
return rook c1 check has played
fabi hides his king and i hope
everybody's following so far we're
reaching that final end game
if anybody has questions or wants me to
repeat something please don't hesitate
and now knight g6 by maxime attacking
the rook and attacking the pawn now the
rook can't abandon the other rook you
can't go to e4
because then you drop the rook don't
forget that you have to keep the king
pinned
but that means dropping the h fund so
knight h4 rook h5
but on the plus side fabie goes rook h7
and this really shows how good rooks are
at being long range pieces
they can swing from one side of the
board to the other effortlessly
and it's clear that mbl is going to lose
this pawn as well
and he doesn't try particularly hard to
cling to it
what he does decide is that he's going
to trade
another pair of rooks and he's going to
consider
uh or he's going to seek his chances in
this end game
now it's important again to point out
that this pawn is not going to be
uh sustained by the knight there's no
way that the knight is going to be able
to defend this pawn in the long run and
nbl doesn't even try because rook d6
if ambiel goes knight before this could
only backfire could get the knight
trapped
right and then fabby's gonna go rook b6
then rook b5
so mbl says all right whatever i'm going
to go 95 i'm going to give this spot up
and we're going to get
what's going to i think become a very
very famous end game very famous end
game
there's one two three four five six
pieces this is a table base
end game and initially it was a table
based draw
now there's a couple of things which
must be established for you guys to
understand
this end game the first thing is that
rook against knight unless there are
particularly extenuating circumstances
like the knight is on a1
is a draw work against that is a draw
so simply trading puns would not
be helpful to white now
if we can let's try to understand this
conceptually how do we even understand
this end game
why does it look like like a lot well it
looks like a drop because it looks like
black has a fortress
in order to win the game black is going
to have to win the f6 pawn
right that's not a controversial
statement and
that's incredibly hard to do because the
knight simply keeps the king away
and the rook alone is not going to be
able to win this pawn
now as you're thinking about it maybe
you developed the idea
of bringing the pawn to g5 and using the
pin to win the pawn well that's also
easier said than done is the knight's
not going to relinquish its control of
the g5 square
in order to make progress then white has
to go one step
before winning the pawn in order to
think about how to trick black fabby
must have been thinking well
what let's work backwards let's reverse
engineer this
what needs to happen in order for me to
win the f6 spawn
well he comes up with a pretty clear
statement thank you red hobo for the
five
he's going to have to push black's king
back at some point so that white's king
can come to f5 and
try to maneuver around the knights
checks
white's going to have to push black's
defensive construction off the board
and does that make sense that's the
target position
that's what they're fighting over
they're fighting over king position if
white can get his king to f5 or e6
probably black's not going to be able to
hold on and pry the king away from the
pawn but if
mvl can can hold this construction in
one way or another
he's going to be able to hold a drop
okay
so if abby shuffles for a little bit he
goes king e4 rook a5
knight f7 mbl just goes back and forth
and
he goes knight f5 notice that fabi tries
to give a check on g3 mbl just stops
them whether or not this check is
dangerous
remains to be c in rook t3 this is kind
of zum the knight has to move
and now comes the most important
position in the game i haven't checked
the engine on this
uh grandmaster posted on facebook evgeny
posny
um that
okay not this but like not yet not yet
not yet this is still fine i think
and perhaps somebody could correct me on
this this is still fine
i think the critical moment comes so
they're shuffling around
now notice how fabi has okay knight h6
was the blunder apparently
i don't think it is let me check i'm
going to check table bases myself just
to make sure i'm not lying to you guys
yes caro is correct knight h6 is the
decisive mistake
okay knight h6 is decisive mistake
made in 43 no this is the decisive
mistake
and then and then
fabi makes a mistake and then mbl
makes a mistake here or the second
knight h6 so this is still fine
let me see
wow knight c7 that's just insane this is
so
complicated
i'm just checking something yeah this is
going to be very hard to understand okay
so i think i've understood it i've
understood at least one thing
in order to try to understand this end
game
we need to create a target position end
rough b
a target position is a position which if
we reach if we reach this position we
know the evaluation
and if we reason back from target
positions
we can understand what they're fighting
for because otherwise like these moves
have no meaning
why is this move bad why is that move
good
now to me it seems that the target
position is one
in which white's king has reached h5
so let me make a couple of random moves
here
let's say we have this position okay now
we know
as i've said earlier that eventually the
king wants to reach upon
but this represents a lot of progress uh
robert
robert hess made a very insightful point
in the commentary or i think
how old it or somebody did the king on
the
h file is very hard to check the knight
only has a couple of ways to check this
king
there's no way to pry the king away from
the h file if you consider the king
on f5 right particularly in this
position
king can't hold on to its uh enviable
perch the knight just goes 97
and because of the coordinated efforts
of this and this the king has to come
back right
i hope that makes sense but if you
consider the king on h5
and you consider a knight check the king
doesn't have to go back to g4 it can go
up to h6 and further up to h7 and it's
going to evade the checks one way or
another
okay so why is that a big deal you might
ask okay great like
i don't care 97. well now
i feel like using the rook uh to corral
black's king and cause zug's bong
white can inch the king further toward
g7 this is not easy to do
but it appears to me that one plan
is to go rook f3
now you're x-raying the pawn
and if the nitrous chills
i think the g4 the aforementioned plan
of
pushing the spawn to g5 might be winning
here
and one amazing line that i'm seeing
guys oh my god what does one have in
this position find white's fastest win
this is pretty cool
this is pretty cool
i think what is g5 not necessary but
cool
g6 g7 and it just shows you how bad the
knight is
at stopping passers on the corner of the
board check
king g6 and it's a win that's a pretty
cool line unnecessary but cool
but all of this shows the king has to
step aside in order to escape the pin
and now you go kg7 shouldering black's
king
and at this point all that remains is
some map of work rook f4
knight and uh
one thing that comes to mind is is rook
f5
the idea is to tie yourself to this well
i guess work on five king e6
maybe just check and if 95 then the
undermining move g5
wins because you can't take and if the
king moves aside
then we've reached our essentially our
ideal position that's it black is going
to lose this game
it's going to lose the f1 so
does this part make sense does it make
sense why and i've
i've shown this very approximately i'm
sure there's more subtleties there
the bottom line to understand is that if
white's king reaches the h file
this becomes very unpleasant for black
because it's hard to pry the king away
from h5 and eventually the king will
reach g6
and have a serious shot at winning the
pawn
so the battle revolves in a sense
around stop around mbl stopping fabby's
king from reaching h5
but to reach h5 white will have to do
two things why we'll have to
get the king away from g6 at some point
and make sure that the knight isn't like
on g7
at that moment because that will bar the
passage to h5
okay so what happens here
is i assume the move knight h6 is a
mistake because it allows
fabi through some crazy sequence to
force his king onto h5
so king so let's understand using table
bases right we're going to turn table
base on here just so i can
guide you guys through this what happens
here why is this a mistake
so fabi begins correctly the correct
move by the way which
held the draw was either 97 or knight g7
now i understand why knight g7 is good i
understand it because
the knight guards h5 we agree that this
is the target position
so for example of check here here here
congratulations see this is the key
position guys
the knight holds the h5 square if you
try to induce zooxvon
the king can just go back to f8 and
forward to f7
but the question is well what is the
significance of nitrous
why is this bad because this stops the
king chrome coming to g4
so this is correct by fabi mbl
ghost king f7 fabby plays king e4 that
is correct
now this is a pretty nasty situation for
mbl
because if he goes king to e6
then after rook b3 king back
now rook c3 is the move what's going to
happen here rook
g3 oh that's the zooxvan
so king e6 rook h3 yeah so this makes a
lot of sense
i'm just i'm just running through the
line to understand what's going on
oh now we're okay six so this knight on
a6 is going to
end up in a lot of trouble that's pretty
crazy even i don't understand the
sequence fully but
the bottom line is after knight g8
yep here comes king g4 and here's king
h5 and this is the fastest one
so the reason that
this is losing uh is because
the knight will not have enough squares
to shuffle between and eventually
you're going to create zouzong with a
knight on h6 and forcing the king
uh to to go to g4 now what is the the
purpose of these
crazy rook maneuvers well you want to
basically catch black's king
at a certain point so that you can do
stuff if you go
rook g3 here immediately then black can
go knight g8
and if you try to escape the gates if
you try to cross the gates
nope then knight h6 ah shut down
right so you're trying to create a
situation and rex c3 is a waiting move
where um where black has to make a move
that damages his fortress if black drops
the knight back to g8
then you go king f4 knight h6
rook g3 and there's the zooxvong
there's the zugswang if king f8 and you
slide the rook in
and you can walk the king around already
to h5 or you can go king f5 and this is
just winning after rook takes g8
with the winning pawn end game
so this is wang because if knight g8
then
um if king f8 rook g6 if knight g8
who can tell me the move so just to make
sure that you guys are understanding
where we're going with this what's the
purpose of all of this you know what the
target position is now we can reach the
target position how
king g4 you get the king to h5
and if king g6 then you go king h4 check
essentially using this pin forcing the
king back and we've reached the target
position which we already know is
winning
so in a sense that's all there is to it
you
you have to waste a move in this
position
uh to force either black's knight back
which allows white's king to f4 or force
what black's king to move
which gives white a chance to deliver
this check which
uh creates the zooxbox position we've
already discussed
and it appears to me that knight h6 is a
mistake because
the knight is not able to shuffle
between enough squares
when you bring the knight in the center
it has more squares that it can shuffle
between here
white can cause the zooxvan because the
knight essentially only has one squares
the king cannon f7 is blocking the
knight from a very important shuffle
square
okay so let's see
how knight g7 we already saw ng7 here
white can waste all the moves that he
wants to waste
right why can't waste all the moves he
wants to waste
the knight cannot be dislodged from g7
this is a literal fortress
this knight is stopping white's king
from coming to h5
and black's king has enough squares that
it can go to so that the knight
essentially never has to move
a zooxan is a position in which every
move causes harm to your position
okay so let's see what what fabi did
knight h6 boom boom boom
he goes king e4 correctly mbl goes
knight g8
fabi repeats moves king f5 king f4 that
does
nothing but the the amazing thing is
that nbl's knight
is unable to reach g7 that's the
critical square for the knight but here
fabi makes a mistake he goes king g4
and that mistake allows black to make a
drop the correct approach would have
been to repeat moves
and then get back on the right track
with this rugby three idea rugby
three and then rook b6
and now the win is elementary all right
you can go king f5
and king chief oh no king g4 you can't
go because of king g6 so no it's not
elementary
but the move is rogue v6 and actually g3
ah and that's the zooxvan rook b7 tying
down the king
and now who can tell me the winning idea
here once the king gets to e6 the target
position is very easily reachable where
should whites can go
boom boom
boom easy target position king on h5 and
we already have discussed that this is
winning
so all of this revolves around the
king's ability to get to h5
and both posturing for position trying
to prevent the other from getting it
done
fabi goes king g4 and this blocks the
rook's axis of the g
file which allowed king g6 mbl played it
mbl correctly goes king f7 and all of a
sudden
now the knight can reach g7 again mvl
simply did not understand that the
correct drawing plan
is to put the knight on g7 that is the
only drawing plan
now what is the fastest path that the
knight has the g7
ladies and gentlemen it's to go here and
that's why the computer suggests that
move
the king can try to reach h5 almost
there but no
knight g7 just in time we already know
this is a draw now black has a complete
fortress
does it am i making any sense i hope i'm
making some sense here
at least in the sense of like describing
what they're fighting over
it's very hard for me because even i
don't understand entirely the point of
all of these crazy moves
but i think we've figured out what both
sides are fighting for and
what the general ideas here are so 97 is
the mistake and now fabi goes back to
the right plan
king e4 and
fabi goes rook h3 stopping king h6 and
this is all fine
king g6 rook a3
and what happens here he finally reverts
back to the correct idea
mbl doesn't put up much of a fight
because sorry
so knight g8 because we already know
that this is the keys huge bang position
we had this in our analysis earlier
and once again this is zoox bomb classic
zooxbox
mvl moved his knight which allowed fabi
to reach the target position anyone soon
after
if the king had moved i remind you that
we slide the rook and force the knight
back
and the easiest is to go king f5 here
wait a minute isn't this a fork well no
because this is a winning pawn end game
yeah lionel carter i'll explain in a
second
if the king goes to e6 well then the
same thing is possible here here
here sorry king g4 probably not the
fastest but possible
and so mvl goes knight g8 fabby gets his
king to h5 he understood that this is
the idea
and much as we discussed he plays g4 the
king
can go back to f7 but then g5 wins fabi
just pushes the spawn all the way to g6
and this wins and so mbl has to stick
around here and he resigns after k26
because
if 97 check the king slides into f7
and who can tell me what the fastest win
is here well you see the computer so
rook f5
rook takes d5 now somebody was asking me
to show uh why it's a draw with a knight
on g7 why was that the key drawing idea
absolutely so the reason that's a
fortress
is and let's go back to the last moment
in which we had a chance to do that
so here knight c7 king f4 knight e6
sorry 96 king g4 knight g7 what if
white's rook swings around
and you try to push black off the board
well first of all you can now move the
knight because the king is on g6
so you can go here but you can probably
also go here
yes and why cannot make progress
right there's just nothing that white
can do white has to eventually move the
king
now white can try to go around the other
way
but at some point you can just try to
win this pawn with your knight
so yeah and once you push the jeep on
there's really no winning attempts
because
now uh you can you can know you can't go
knight g7 you can go knight c7
the problem with pushing the g pawn is
that the pathway to h5 has been shut
down by the pawn
and if you go g5 then you blunder a fork
black will always have one of these
checks so that's why the knight on g7
would have made a drop
that's what mvl missed what he missed
was the significance
of allowing white's king to come to age
five
that was what the whole battle revolved
around that's why fabi
made a mistake by going king g4 fabi
himself did not realize
at least initially he realized it later
which is absolutely insane
he realized later that when black snipe
does not have access to g7 you could
induce zhuxwang
one way or another by pushing black off
and uh and creating a situation where
the king forcibly
either reaches g4 or you force black's
pieces to the side of the board and then
win the pawn
you could i mean yeah without the engine
you could you could you could figure
this out but
it would be very very hard it would take
many many hours
well how do i figure out that this is
the target well
i reasoned logically that you if you're
trying to win this with white you want
to win the pot
to win the pawn you need to get your
king close to the pond
and we already figured out that the f5
is not the proper way to do it
because the f5 square will always be
checked by black's knight so the
just that is nothing to do with chess
directionally speaking the only other
pathway to the pawn
is to go from the h from the h file to
g6
and we know that the king is very hard
to dislodge from the h file especially
by the knight
and so that's why we want to go there
mvl thought that he could stop it with
his knight being on h6 because it
controls g4
failing to realize that eventually his
knight would be pried off of that square
right this being the critical zug's
bottom position this is the zug's bomb
black has to make a decisive weakening
of his position allowing the king to
come to h5
and uh that concludes the analysis mbl
officially resigned
after kg6 because his pieces have been
pushed off and the pawn will be lost
[Music]
you